no matter what it is chances are some  nanny wants to ban it the nanny of the  month runners-up Fairfax County Virginia  police for arresting this guy after a  woman saw him making coffee naked in his  own home when police confronted him for  illegally showing his business he was  stunned in the Los Angeles City Council  for extending its ban on new fast food  restaurants in South LA but there's only  one nanny of the month and this time  it's New York State Senator Jeff Klein  for trying to ban fish pedicures that's  right fish pedicures tiny toothless carp  nibble away at dead skin it's big in  Japan the client calls fish pedicures  dirty and dangerous and introduced a  bill that would ban them statewide so  how many foot mangled victims of fish  pedicures are there according to the  State Department that regulates beauty  salons so far there have been zero  complaints check back next month for  more examples busybodies minding your  own business  you